we're back ladies and gentlemen with
episode 2 of the supremely mind-bending
maniac so take your pills and settle in
because it's gonna get weird
well episode one focused on Owen episode
two focuses on Annie here in her
apartment were struck with a vast
contrast from the structured
businesslike world of Owen Milgram
clutter adorns the room and highlighted
is a book of modern art not surprising
considering a 2013 study from the
University of Minnesota concluded that
those that keep cluttered houses are
often more creative and he pulls out a
pill bottle and has a few harsh words
with the last remaining tablet shaped
like an a before crushing it and
snorting the residue like cocaine what
follows is a seemingly euphoric
experience seen in fast motion as a
roommates blur about their day around
her you'll notice here more rainbow
imagery harkening back to never Dean any
awakens from her high with a tear
rolling down her face as Flash Gordon
plays on the TV she pulls out a cigar
box where we see her copy of Don Quixote
that she pulled from the trash in
episode 1 inferring the events here take
place after the opening of that episode
we get a view of scars on Annie's back a
reference to the events at the end of
this episode as she pulls out a pitcher
who will later learn is her sister Ellie
before getting to work on a lost dog
poster she glares once more at the pill
bottle and we get a few more clues as to
where it came from more Japanese
lettering in the words saying trial ULP
phase 3 confirming its connection to NBP
and owens ULP screening there's also the
letter a like the pill and this is a
test outside and he puts up the lost dog
posters and we get a look at her
creation might be a little too late
looking for a dog lost seven years ago
but take note of the woman in the
picture it's her sister not her at a
noodle shop and he takes in a few ads
from ad buddy I'm guessing this is how
Annie paid for her meal as well later
learn she's having trouble paying the
rent when buddy here mentions the
limitless options they can offer and he
expresses a desire to reach Salt Lake
City to see her sister and wonders if ad
buddy could pay the way but he says it
should only take a few thousand ads
hikes
back home and he packs a bag and picks
up Don Quixote claiming she's healthy
and he now
no more pills it's no coincidence that
Don Quixote is referenced so much the
stories of a noble who loses his sanity
reading too many chivalrous romances and
takes on a quest to revive chivalry Don
Quixote does not see the world as it
really is and prefers to imagine he is
living out a Knightly story sound like
anyone we know however Annie's quest to
reach Salt Lake City is thwarted due to
lack of funds and she pays a visit to
her dad Hank a cross between Hal from
2001 a Space Odyssey and a vampire
coffin Hank has hidden away from the
world in an a void seemingly as a way of
avoiding his problems mainly the sorrow
he feels from Annie's mother's passing
I'm also getting big Back to the Future
vibes from these numbers yet another
homage to the 80s
Annie hits up dad safe for some bus
money and we see a gun could this be the
same gun she makes reference to in
Episode one she becomes a visibly upset
which is no surprise considering her dad
has locked himself away but this doesn't
seem to stop her from taking a lot more
than a few bucks for the bus with cash
in hand she grabs her bag and heads out
notice the same style painting here in
her apartment as in her dad's place
before entering the terminal we get a
glimpse at the soldiers and sailors arch
at Grand Army Plaza in Brooklyn that has
been covered in neon lights inside the
bus terminal and he purchases a ticket
to Salt Lake City but hallucinates while
looking at the rolling bus numbers the
entire board forms the letter a while
Owens issues stem from his schizophrenia
and he seems to be an addiction to this
mysterious a drug the drug has won this
day and she needs more at Washington
Square Park and he meets up with her
supplier Calvin he's playing a classic
game of New York chess with a purple
robotic gambling koala turns out Pillay
isn't something you can just order
whenever you want
Calvin snatched it from his dad who
works for NBP and can't get her anymore
any pleads for a lead but he tells her
MVP has gotten way more secretive since
the suicides but after a knee drop some
bus money he gives the name of Knepper
Dean's intake director Patricia Lugo any
visits doc shop an establishment which
helps find dirt on others by gaining
access to people's personal information
it's essentially the opposite of the
identity stolen ad from episode 1 and
wouldn't you love the irony of the same
ad off
the side here inside Annie drops more of
her dad's cash to blackmail Patricia
Lugo looks like they don't take add
buddy in exchange for daxing apparently
Patricia has a disorderly arrest on her
record was a gambler and lost custody of
her daughter then had it all scrubbed so
she could get her job at never Dean for
a fee mr. doc says he'll even threaten a
kidnapper kid that [ __ ] always works
instead he finds she's a user something
called friend proxy for pretend friends
a service not unlike daddy's home where
someone fills in as your friend it's
clear this world is really painted as
one of loneliness people lacking
connection
Annie intercepts Patricia at a Botanical
Garden notice all the bonsai trees which
make a number of appearances at the NBP
labs she pretends to be her proxy friend
Juanita and noticed the friend proxy pin
she wears just like the man from episode
one but after a slip-up in her story and
a glance over at two young girls in the
garden
perhaps reminding Annie of herself and
her sister she gives up the goat and
retreats if you recall this young girl
here is owns niece that we saw at
episode one but rather than counting
herself lucky and leaving Patricia
follows Annie maybe that's how desperate
for a human connection she is Annie
explains the reasons she blackmailed
Patricia is to get into the never teen
trials because she needs more of those
pills the only thing that makes her feel
better about her relationship with her
sister she describes a cold rock that
has been left in her stomach by an
argument they had five years ago
Patricia tells her she could reach out
to her sister but Annie says I can't
the story works and Annie gets to take
the defense mechanism tests that Owen
did in Episode one he or she gives
answers she thinks the screener wants to
hear such as super happy and
togetherness perhaps the only response
close to a real one is her reaction of
sisters making faces at each other the
screener then does the final stare down
but Annie just holds her vitals rising
before getting the red light guess her
defense mechanisms weren't fungible a
pissed-off
Annie decides to take mr. docks his
original advice and blackmail Patricia
saying if she doesn't get into her study
she'll never see her daughter again
guess he was right that [ __ ] always
works
now the story starts to connect from
episode 1 as we cut to Owens staring
Annie down he heads in for his
ULP test while patricia upgrades another
tester to a much much safer trial and
hands annie her golden ticket we arrive
back in the pot room and are treated to
an introduction video in our first look
at dr mantle ray played here by justin
theroux who does a fantastic job of that
acting his last name you might remember
from the ad Annie passes in Episode one
could greet a mantle ray be his mother I
gotta say this was one of my favorite
parts of the whole episode the 80s VHS
style effects the specific cuts made in
the video no one sees inside your head
says dr. Moreau moto assuredly than six
seconds later the videos purpose is to
explain how the test works and it's
simple three pills taken in three steps
analyzed by the most sophisticated mega
computer ever developed the GRT a eerily
similar to grita
after ingesting the pills the machines
cutting-edge artificial intelligence
will identify map and confront the
learned programming of your brain simple
right pill a Annie's pill is called a
Gonia which in Greek translates to of
severe mental struggles and emotions
agony anguish this pill pulls at your
core traumas and worst memories of your
life and maps them for pill B and C pill
be behavioural identifies your minds
defense mechanisms and blind spots pill
C confer Exia confrontation the end of
the rainbow likely why we've seen so
many rainbows referenced throughout the
show once pill a and B have worked greet
áwill remap your brain and voila you're
cured simple right
dr. Moreau moto asks if anyone has
questions and then ignores the ones who
do and lets the evens know they're going
to get a delicious pre-weighed meal
while the odds hit the microwave chairs
as an e lines up for the tests we get a
look into dr. Fujita's control room
notice some of the shoulders of the
workers who have yellow stripes and the
one man on the right who has blue or
indigo suggesting the rainbow colors of
MBP separate into different departments
of the company in the lineup Owen tells
Annie everyone thought he was crazy but
they were wrong any replies they'll talk
about this later she's going along with
him as to not attract
tension in the supercomputer room we
find dr. Moreau moto reading a poem to
grita
it's William Blake's the angel poem
suggesting that she is seen as a
guardian angel it seems like greed is
more complex than a regular computer and
enjoys this poetry almost as if she has
emotions later dr. Fujita implies
Greta's safety-net is connected to how
much she liked the poem the odds get
placed in their chairs and are donned
with x-ray vests straight out of your
dentist's office
dr. Fujita addresses her crew and
explains the test subject data over the
next three days is vital to their
success and that the subjects lives are
in their hands no more mistakes
finally Annie gets her pill and the
Machine fires up electrical wires get
sent from the chairs to the computer
wires depicting the connection from each
participant can be seen with one being
Owen and nine being Annie
dr. Fujita instructs the crew to be
gentle on that hard entry is their enemy
in Annie's mind we see a Dutch windmill
windmill being the title of this episode
and a sign saying leave to the
nightingale her shady woods this is a
reference to William Wordsworth's poem
called to a Skylark the poem itself
about a skylarks connection to its roots
while also flying high but of interest
is the line leave to the nightingale her
shady would the nightingale is a
songbird that unlike the Skylark keeps
to the woods is an ER nightingale and
her sister the Skylark in this memory
and he pumped some gas and sports a new
short hairdo as her sister Ellie comes
from inside we can assume this memory is
at least five years or older as we know
from the earlier conversation with
Patricia that this is how long it's been
since the two last spoke and considering
this is a pill a memory aka a Gonia it's
also likely the origin of Annie and her
sisters falling out cute sister hijinks
ensue that night in a motel room the two
costs over their tumultuous relationship
with their mother and escaped into
fantasy Ellie explains her moved to Salt
Lake City is because of her fiance and
opens up about her fears of stability
she's afraid she'll screw it up and this
screw up her future kids just like what
happened to the sisters but in this
fantasy Ellie explains she doesn't screw
up she has her happy ending rather than
act supportive annie pushes back and
they argue Ellie brings up the fact that
Annie can't take care of anything which
Annie assumes is a reference to Ellie's
dog inferring that she lost him they
sling more insults calling each other
mom and Annie gets mean stating how
happy she is that Ellie is moving far
away
the next morning Annie begins a careful
attempt to reconcile and decides to take
a serious picture with her sister Ellie
holds the wheel as Annie goes to take a
selfie but eventually Annie makes
another joke of it as the to grapple
over the camera a truck comes barreling
down the wrong side of the road and
plows into them sending Annie and Ellie
over the side of the road annie is flung
from her car and lives while her sister
is left to die in the wreckage below
thus why Annie explained she can't
reconcile to Lugo here amongst the blood
you can also see the fresh scar wounds
on Annie's back the same place her scars
were seen at the beginning of the
episode back in the test room we see a
crying Annie similar to what happened on
her couch the last time she took the
pill pill a has located her trauma but
what kind of effect has the pill had on
Owens brain and what will pills be and
see how for them down the line thanks
again for watching if you liked this
series please make sure to like and
share it there's a whole lot more to
unpack in the upcoming episodes so I
hope you'll join me until next time